I'm Lynn George I'm the CEO of Sun run
changing the future of energy here in
the US Sun one's business model is to
offer basically solar as a service to
consumers so consumers like solar energy
they get it but they think it's
expensive they think it's a lot of work
to you know figure out exactly what kind
of technology they want to put on the
rooftop so we took away all those
problems by going to a homeowner and
saying we'll pay to install the system
on your roof you just essentially have
to lend us your roof and then we'll just
bill you each month for your electricity
just like your utility company but it's
actually cheaper and it's green and it's
produced on your rooftop
back in business school of my classmate
at Fenster approached me and said I have
an idea we just looked at the market and
it was just so obviously huge I mean
there are very few opportunities to
enter a market where even in its
earliest phase you know you can undercut
six billion dollars in annual sales and
so you just felt like it intrinsically
made sense and you know is the sort of
the classic you know Business School
Gees if I could just get 1% of this pie
you know this works and so you just had
conviction around that it wasn't one of
these scenarios where we spent a ton of
time doing research or writing business
plans we just said let's go try to bid
on a project we started while we were at
Stanford the company was run for seven
months you know half of the Attic of my
house in San Francisco and you know we'd
be up in the roof of my house you know
on cellphones trying to get these deals
to happen and we bid and I think it was
British Telecom wanted to build a big
system on one of their campuses in the
US and we went out and we pitched it we
said we can raise the capital behind
this let's give it a try and we
certainly didn't win that deal but it
made us realize that there was a market
and that we had a business and we
quickly pivoted over to the consumer end
market as opposed to the commercial on
market and that was a wise choice
we had no idea a lot of the ups and
downs along the way how painful it would
be how many sleepless nights we would
have it was a frightening ride for the
first couple years you know obviously as
we were just starting to close our first
project finance transaction over the
summer of 2008 you know the whole world
melted down you know we ended up closing
our first project finance fund the day
of the SP an eleven year loan in
November of 2008 and so when the markets
collapsed you know we were sitting there
faced with can we get this capital
raised do we have to shut the business
down it did also happen that you know in
the end of 2008 the law is subsidizing
solar all changed we had to restart
business and I remember ed and I looked
at each other and we just said we're
gonna get it done because we have to we
have no choice and so it's just you just
look straight forward you don't look at
that you don't turn to the side and you
just go for it in January 2009
you know we had 9 cents we have four
digits of monthly new origination
now we have raised the capital to
purchase about two billion dollars in
residential solar facilities about 1.6
billion of which we've purchased and
that growth is almost hard to sort of
comprehend because the business isn't
that much different it's just the number
of zeros kind of in the columns keep
increasing oftentimes when you go to
business school it's so easy to take a
safe career you know it's easy to get a
great consulting job or investing job or
investment banking job and and
oftentimes a lot of these you know smart
MBAs want to poke holes in businesses
and I think Stanford is unique in that
it really teaches you the analytical
skills to assess a business but without
losing that hope without losing that
optimism
that sort of resilience that's sort of
not giving up works and you know it's
common among many entrepreneurs when I
talk to my colleagues and you know
almost everybody has had those moments
where it feels as though there's no way
to succeed but what's common about the
people who do is that they don't give up
don't give up that's the secret
[Music]
you